-Welcome back. We are here with
Anya Taylor-Joy everybody now.
[ Cheers and applause ]
Anya, you're such
a talented actress.
I told you I'm a big fan.
You can make everything
dramatic.
And since your latest movie is
all about food, we thought
we could put your acting skills
to the test by re-enacting
real text conversations people
have had with
their delivery drivers.
It's time for
"Dramatic Delivery."
Here we go.
-♪ Dramatic delivery ♪
-Okay.
-Alright.
Now, you should know that all
these texts are real, okay?
For this one, I will be playing
the customer.
You will be playing the driver.
Sound good?
-I'm ready. Got it.
[ Dramatic music plays ]
-Who is this?
-Hello.
Your UberEats order is here.
-Oh, coming!
Are you at the main entrance?
-No.
I'm on top of the building.
I just landed
with my helicopter.
Yes, I'm at the main entrance.
[ Laughter ]
[ Cheers and applause ]
-Just landed in your helicopter.
That's funny.
I like the sarcasm.
-Yes.
Yeah, I kind of want to be
friends with that person.
That was good.
-Alright.
For this one,
I will start this one.
Here we go.
[ Clears throat ]
[ Dramatic music plays ]
What flavor did you want
for your drink?
[ Laughter ]
What flavor did you want
for your drink?
[ Laughter ]
What flavor did you want
for your drink?
[ Laughter ]
What flavor did you want
for your drink?
-Oh, I already got my food.
But, um, thank you. Sorry.
[ Laughter ]
-What flavor did you want
for your drink?
[ Cheers and applause ]
Persistent, persistent.
He's got to get the job done.
-Eventually he will know.
You're just, "Oh, thanks,
I got it, sorry."
Let's do one more here.
I will start this one. Ready?
[ Dramatic music plays ]
They don't any more tomatoes.
Do you still want
the same sandwich?
-Yeah, that's fine. Thanks.
-Aaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaa!
[ Applause ]
-Um, you okay?
-Yeah, my bad.
[ Cheers and applause ]
Aaaaa.
-Aaaaaaaa.
-Alright. Let's do another one.
This time you will start.
-Okay. Yes.
[ Clears throat ]
[ Dramatic music plays ]
Hey, this is
your FoodFetched driver.
On my way!
-Great! You can park
behind my white Subaru.
-I remember where you live.
I've done you before.
[ Laughter ]
-Wait, what?
[ Cheers and applause ]
Alright, let's do one more here.
[ Laughs ]
"I've done you before."
Huh? Alright.
Anya, you start this one.
-Yep. Mm-hmm.
I'm a professional, sorry.
-Me too.
[ Dramatic music plays ]
-Sorry, the restaurant took
forever.
I'm on my way now to you but get
your bitch ass out of my lane!
[ Laughter ]
-L-M-A-O, what?
-Oh, voice text. My bad.
[ Cheers and applause ]
-Get your bitch ass
out of my lane?
Anya Taylor-Joy. "The Menu" is
in theaters this Friday.
Stick around.
We'll be right back with
Glen Powell, everybody.